Pas mal !
Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Je suis sûr que, comme moi,
vous adorez la pétanque.
Alors évidemment,
vous le savez toutes et tous,
c'est un jeu typiquement marseillais
mais qui a conquis le cœur
de tous les Français.
En revanche, savez-vous
comment la pétanque a été inventée ?
Comment on fait un carreau ?
Pourquoi la boule visée est éjectée
alors que la boule tirée reste sur place ?
On va tirer tout ça au clair
avec un joueur prestigieux :
Michel Loy,
champion du monde de pétanque.
Là, il est en train de s'échauffer et moi,
je vais faire la même chose
mais pour ça,
je dois me pointer dans l'atelier.
Pas mal, hein ?
En 2022, la pétanque comptait exactement
255590 licenciés en France.
Ça donne le vertige.
C'est grosso modo
la population de Bordeaux.
Sans compter toutes celles
et ceux qui, comme moi, pratiquent ce jeu
pour se détendre pendant leurs vacances.
Alors, je parle d'un jeu,
mais est-ce un jeu ou un sport ?
Eh bien la pétanque est considérée
comme un sport.
Elle possède sa propre fédération
et de nombreuses compétitions
nationales et internationales
sont organisées.
La toute première édition du championnat du monde a eu lieu en 1959
à Spa en Belgique.
Et sans surprise,
c'est la France qui domine la discipline
en ayant remporté
27 championnats du monde.
Ce point étant précisé,
nous pouvons rejoindre
notre champion du monde, Michel Loy.
On a de la chance, aujourd'hui,
c'est lui qui nous sert de coach.
Wow !
Bonjour Michel.
Bonjour !
Ravi de rencontrer une légende
de la pétanque.
C'est gentil.
Alors dites-moi, on peut jouer
soit en simple, soit en équipe ?
On peut jouer à 1 contre 1, 3 boules chacun.
En doublette, donc, comme le nom l'indique,
2 contre 2 avec 3 boules chacun.
Et en triplette,
3 joueurs de chaque côté
avec 2 boules chacun,
donc 12 boules sur le terrain.
Je peux jeter un œil sur les boules
avec lesquelles vous jouez ?
Oui.
Alors, évidemment, elles sont gravées
au nom du champion
et on va observer
ces boules d'un peu plus près
pour voir comment elles sont fabriquées.
Je vous la rends.
Merci.
Je vais faire un tour dans l'atelier
et je reviens aussitôt après.
À tout à l'heure !
À votre avis,
combien pèse une boule de pétanque ?
Eh bien, on va le savoir tout de suite.
Celle-ci pèse aux alentours
de 700 grammes.
En fait, les boules de pétanque pèsent
en moyenne entre 650 et 800 grammes.
Ce n'est pas très lourd, finalement.
Une brique comme celle-ci fait
presque 2 kilogrammes.
À l'origine, une boule de pétanque,
ça ressemble à ça.
C'est un tronçon d'acier ou de carbone
qui a été découpé
dans une pièce beaucoup plus longue.
On appelle ça un lopin.
Ce lopin est chauffé à 1 200 degrés,
puis il est écrasé entre 2 presses.
On obtient une galette comme celle-ci.
Elle est à nouveau chauffée puis emboutie,
ce qui permet d'obtenir
une demi-sphère creuse.
Et en assemblant 2 demi-sphères,
on obtient une boule de pétanque.
Les boules de pétanque sont donc creuses.
Alors, ça ne nous vient pas à l'idée
car les traces de soudure ont disparu.
Cette boule va être usinée, tournée
pour faire disparaître
ces traces de soudure.
Puis, elle est polie pour la rendre bien
lisse, comme celle-ci.
Son diamètre peut varier
légèrement, de 7 à 8 cm et à ce stade,
il ne reste plus que l'étape
dite du "striage".
Ces stries ne sont pas obligatoires, mais plus il y en a, plus la boule est freinée.
On dit qu'elle stoppe plus facilement.
Pour le cochonnet, le but ou le bouchon,
comme on dit à Marseille,
c'est plus simple.
Il est généralement taillé dans du buis,
un bois très dur qui lui permet
de résister aux chocs et à l'usure.
Attention, il doit faire 30 mm de diamètre
avec une tolérance de plus ou moins 1mm.
Les jeux
de boules existent depuis l'Antiquité.
Pendant longtemps, on y a surtout joué
dans le sud de la France
mais rien à voir avec la pétanque
que l'on pratique aujourd'hui.
Ces règles sont assez récentes,
elles ont été établies
un peu par hasard, au début du XXᵉ siècle,
grâce à un célèbre joueur de boules
atteint de rhumatisme.
En 1907, un champion nommé Jules Hugues, dit “Le Noir”, dispute
une partie de boules provençale
à La Ciotat, près de Marseille.
Les règles de ce jeu obligent
les participants à prendre
2 ou 3 pas d'élan
pour lancer le cochonnet
et les boules,
à une distance de 15 à 20 mètres.
À cette époque,
les boules ne sont pas encore en métal.
Elles sont faites en bois et recouvertes
de clous, en cuivre ou en laiton.
Ce jour-là, Le Noir est victime
d'une grosse crise de rhumatisme.
Il ne peut ni courir
ni lancer ses boules très loin.
Il décide donc de tracer un cercle
sur le terrain, de rester les pieds ancrés
dans le sol et de lancer son cochonnet
à 5 ou 6 mètres seulement.
La pétanque était née.
Mais au fait, pourquoi a t-on nommé
ce nouveau jeu “pétanque” ?
Le terme vient de l'Occitan provençal "pè"
qui signifie pied
et "tanka" qui signifie pieu,
donnant en français régional, l'expression :
“Jouer pés tanqués”, c'est-à-dire
avec les pieds ancrés dans le sol.
À la différence,
je vous le rappelle, de l'ancien jeu
qui consistait à courir
pour lancer le cochonnet et les boules.
Celui qui a les pieds bien ancrés dans
le sol, c'est Michel Loy, notre champion.
Il m'attend pour
me donner une petite leçon.
Ah bah sympa,
c'était ma boule.
Ah ! Je ne savais pas.
Ça m’étonnerait !
Alors quels conseils donneriez-vous
à un joueur débutant comme moi,
un joueur du dimanche ?
Déjà, la position dans le rond parce que
je pense que c'est le plus important,
l'équilibre, de se sentir bien
dans le rond, d’être fléchi sur ses jambes.
On va commencer par le commencement.
Le lancer du cochonnet, du but
ou du bouchon.
En fait, le bouchon doit être jeté
entre 6 mètres et 10 mètres
pour commencer une mène.
Avant de jeter les 12 boules, selon si on joue en doublette, en triplette
ou en tête à tête, les 6 boules,
on appelle ça une mène.
C'est-à-dire que quand on a fini de jeter toutes les boules,
on compte le nombre de points par équipes marqués.
Et à l'intérieur de la mène,
une fois que le bouchon, par exemple,
vous jetez le bouchon à 7 mètres,
il peut très bien bouger
jusqu'à 20 mètres, sur un tir.
Et là, vous jouez jusqu'à 20 mètres et
si ça dépasse 20 mètres,
apparemment, la mène est annulée.
Bon, je me lance.
Allez, soyons fous !
Et là, je vais donc pointer ?
Pointer, c’est ça.
C'est-à-dire s'approcher
le plus proche possible du cochonnet.
C'est ça.
Oh la la... Oh ça manque d'énergie tout ça.
Alors, c'est quoi votre technique à vous ?
Moi, j'essaie d'envoyer en général
à peu près, à ça du bouchon,
en envoyant la boule assez haut,
en mettant un peu de poignée
et en espérant que la boule, après,
va s'arrêter là où je vais l'envoyer.
Vous lancez en cloche,
c'est un très beau geste, d’ailleurs.
Pas mal.
Bien joué !
Avec un petit bec,
comme au billard.
Excellent !
Vous jouez
depuis combien de temps, Michel ?
Une petite quarantaine d'années déjà.
Et vous vous entraînez souvent ?
Non, parce que j'ai mon boulot aussi, qui fait que je joue quand même le week-end,
mais la semaine, je joue très peu.
Et donc là,
c'est à moi de pointer en premier
parce que c'est
moi qui ai jeté le bouchon.
Bravo Michel !
Merci.
Alors, comme vous le voyez, tirer
ce n'est pas aussi simple
sauf quand on a de l'expérience.
Mais les super-champions comme Michel
sont capables de faire encore plus fort.
Un tir extraordinaire
qu'on appelle “le carreau”
et c'est un mouvement assez complexe.
C'est le maximum
qu'on puisse faire quand on tire,
c'est-à-dire que notre boule qui va sortir
de notre main
va remplacer la boule
le plus près du bouchon, en général,
et il va faire un carreau en remplaçant
la boule qui avait le point initialement.
C'est-à-dire que vous allez éjecter
la boule que vous visez et la votre
va rester clouée sur place ?
C’est ça.
On va faire un saut dans l'atelier
pour comprendre ce qui s'est passé
d'un point de vue mécanique
entre ces 2 boules.
Je reviens tout de suite,
Michel.
À tout à l'heure.
Le célèbre savant
anglais Isaac Newton,
qui a vécu à la fin du XVIIᵉ
et au début du XVIIIᵉ siècle,
a mis en évidence ce phénomène
grâce à cet objet un peu hypnotisant
qui désormais porte son nom :
un pendule de Newton.
À chaque fois,
il y a un carreau.
Revenons à la pétanque.
La boule lancée par Michel possède
une énergie,
c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'énergie cinétique.
Facile à retenir, dans cinétique, il y a "ciné"
comme dans cinéma, une racine grecque
qui signifie mouvement, ce qui est le cas
de la boule lancée par Michel.
Elle est en mouvement.
Sa quantité d'énergie dépend,
vous vous en doutez, de la vitesse.
Pour info,
quand la vitesse est multipliée par 2,
l'énergie est multipliée par 4.
Cette énergie dépend aussi
de la masse de la boule.
Le joueur, Michel, tire,
grâce à un petit coup de poignée,
il donne un effet rétro
à la boule pour la faire tourner sur elle-même en marche arrière.
L'objectif de Michel,
c'est de toucher la boule
qu'il souhaite éjecter, pleine bille.
À ce moment là, toute l'énergie de
la boule tirée est transmise
à la boule visée.
Privée d'énergie,
la boule tirée est clouée sur place,
le petit effet rétro l'empêchant
en plus de rouler vers l'avant.
La boule visée, qui vient d’un seul coup
d'emmagasiner de l'énergie, est éjectée.
C'est ce qu'on appelle un "choc élastique".
C'est ce qu'Isaac Newton a mis
en évidence avec ce pendule pour montrer
la conservation de la quantité
de mouvement et d'énergie cinétique.
Michel, il faut combien de temps
pour maîtriser ce geste ?
Je pense qu'au départ,
il faut seulement avoir un petit don
mais après, comme tous les sports,
il faut le travailler, le travailler
et puis essayer d'arriver à son maximum.
Il faut un peu de patience ?
Oui, c'est sûr, c'est sûr, c'est sûr.
Et puis de l'entraînement, c'est sûr
que c'est l'entraînement au départ
et après, être capable de faire ce qu'on
fait à l'entraînement en compétition,
c'est ce qui fait aussi la différence
entre peut-être le joueur moyen
et, après, le joueur un peu plus chevronné
qui fait des résultats.
Alors, est-ce que les joueurs jouent
toujours avec les mêmes boules ?
Moi, c'est toujours les mêmes boules
comme ça, au moins, je me dis :
si je ne joue pas bien, ce n'est pas
à cause des boules, c'est de ma faute.
Mais beaucoup de joueurs s'adaptent
selon les terrains, selon leur position
dans la triplette.
Parce que le meilleur jeu,
c'est le triplette, à 3.
Vous avez le pointeur,
le milieu et le tireur.
Et selon si vous faites milieu ou tireur,
selon les terrains,
les cailloux, de la roulette,
vous pouvez changer
et de poids et de diamètre.
Mais la boule du tireur n'est pas
forcément la même que celle du pointeur ?
La logique voudrait que la boule du tireur
soit plus légère
et un peu plus grosse,
et pour le pointeur,
d'être un peu plus lourde
pour s'adapter au terrain.
Logiquement, c'est comme ça mais encore une fois chacun fait comme il veut.
Alors quand on est joueur de pétanque,
on doit être bon,
je dirais à tous les postes,
mais vous, est-ce qu'il
y a un poste que vous préférez ?
Moi, quand j'étais jeune,
j'essaie de me rappeler,
j'étais tireur de tête.
Après, j'ai joué
avec un des plus forts tireurs,
donc je me suis adapté au milieu.
C'est-à-dire que normalement,
ma vraie place est milieu, je pointe et je tire. Donc polyvalent.
On essaye.
Bon, bah, en tout cas
merci beaucoup Michel
pour ces conseils et cette démonstration.
Je vais m'entraîner tout l'été
et promis quand je suis prêt,
on se fera une partie.
Pas de soucis.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a donné
envie de vous mettre ou vous remettre
à la pétanque.
Si vous avez aimé, n'hésitez pas à liker
et à vous abonner.
Je vous souhaite
une excellente fin de journée.
Si vous ne savez pas quoi faire,
eh bien jouez à la pétanque.
Bonne semaine et à dimanche prochain,
chers Épicurieuses et Épicurieux !
Tiens, on devrait organiser
un concours de pétanque Épicurieux.
Ça serait une bonne idée
et sachez en tout cas
que le club de Fontenay-sous-Bois
sera toujours là pour vous
ouvrir les portes.
Au plaisir de vous revoir.
Et je jouerai.
Encore mieux.
J’espère !